JAMES GRIME: Today, Brady,
we're going to
look at Smith numbers.
And Smith numbers were born
in an unusual place.
They were born in a telephone
directory when somebody was
looking up the phone number of
their brother-in-law and wrote
down the number, and then
realized it had some unusual
properties.
493-7775--
BRADY HARAN: And that's
a Smith number?
JAMES GRIME: That's
a Smith number.
BRADY HARAN: And whose
number was it?
JAMES GRIME: It was, in
fact, Harold Smith.
And he was, I think, the
brother-in-law of Albert
Wilansky, who was trying to
contact him and found him in
the phone directory.
So Wilansky made the
breakthrough in realizing that
there was some nice property
about this particular number.
So this is, perhaps, a bit big
to start off with in defining
a Smith number.
But a Smith number is
a special number.
The sum of the integers that
make up the number is the same
as the sum of the prime
factors of the number.
27 is a Smith number.
Well, first of all, let me
just write out the prime
factors of 27.
So 27 can be written in
the following way--
3 times 3 times 3.
OK.
Now, let me do the following.
Add these two numbers together
that make 27--
2 plus 7.
And you'll notice that that's
equal to the sum
of the prime factors--
3 plus 3 plus 3,
which equals 9.
And that's what makes
up a Smith number.
A famous one, the one that
you've already covered in
Numberphiles, which is
the beast number--
666.
So that breaks into 2 times
3 times 3 times 37.
OK?
If you multiply these together,
you'll get back 666.
Now, let's add these
digits together.
So 6 plus 6 plus 6--
and that is the same as
2 plus 3 plus 3--
and now comes the subtle bit.
You don't add 37.
You break 37 up into
its digits.
So let me put 3 plus 7.
And hopefully, this works.
6 plus 6 plus 6 is 18.
2 plus 3 is 5 plus 3 is 8 plus
3 is 11 plus 7 is 18.
And so that's why 666 is
also a Smith number.
Let's go to the original
Smith number.
And let's have a
go at that one.
What gets me is how he
realized that this
was going to work.
First of all, get the
prime factors.
So it's 3 times 5 times
5 times 65,837.
It's that bit that I really
think is really neat.
What we can do is add
up the digits
that make up the number.
4 plus 9 plus 3--
plus 5.
And this should equal 3 plus 5
plus 5 plus-- and then we do
this trick, right?
We break this up into its
individual digits--
plus 3 plus 7.
I hope this works, Brady,
otherwise I'm
looking a right idiot.
4 plus 9 is 13 plus 3 is 16--
plus 5 is 42.
BRADY HARAN: 42!
JAMES GRIME: Yay.
OK.
Let me confidently
write 42 there.
And now, let's check
if it works here.
5 plus 5 is 10 plus 3 is 13--
plus 10 is 42.
It worked.
BRADY HARAN: There we go.
It's a Smith number.
JAMES GRIME: And that's
a Smith number.
BRADY HARAN: Do you
like those ones?
JAMES GRIME: I like
that number.
I think it's really nice.
BRADY HARAN: What do
you like about it?
JAMES GRIME: I like the fact
that, first of all, it's a
number where you've broken
it down into its--
I'm a physicist, right?
I believe in building
blocks, quarks, the
building blocks of matter.
These are the building blocks
of mathematics, right?
The prime numbers are
the building blocks.
So you first of all,
can break it down
into those prime numbers.
And then, somehow, by just
adding together these prime
numbers, you get a property of
the original number over and
above the original property,
which was you multiply the
primes together.
It just has a nice additional
feature to it.
4937775--
am I speaking to this person?
BRADY HARAN: Just to
see what happens.
AUTOMATED VOICE: --recognized.
Please check the number.
If you need help, call
the operator on
100 from your mobile.
JAMES GRIME: Oh, well.
He's probably had it
disconnected he's so cheesed
off with people ringing him.
What really blew me away was
when I discovered what the
biggest known Smith number is.
And I thought I'd write that one
down for you, because I'm
not sure how they were
able to check it all.
OK.
It's a big one.
So 10 to the power 1,031 minus
1-- that 1's very important.
OK.
That's all multiplying
the following--
10 to the power of 4,594
plus 3 times 10 to the
2,297 plus 1 again.
And all of that bracket is
raised to the power 1,476.
And that's not the end of it.
That, then, all gets
multiplied by 10
to the power 3,913,210.
And this is the largest
known Smith number.
In fact, in terms of the little
mass, it's given as 16
times 100 to the power n, where
I'm going to let this
number n vary.
So if n is 0--